la siguiente gráfica de dispersión
muestra un conjunto de datos variados
con su recta de regresión de mínimos
cuadrados considera a eliminar el valor
atípico 95 1 este de aquí y calcula una
nueva recta de regresión de mínimos
cuadrados qué efectos tendrá eliminar el
valor atípico elige todas las respuestas
que apliquen como siempre pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo por su
cuenta veamos aún teniendo este valor
atípico tenemos una recta de regresión
con pendiente positiva por lo que parece
que nuestra r ya es mayor a 0 y por
supuesto es menor que 1 sabemos que no
va a ser igual a 1 porque de ser así
pasaría exactamente por todos los puntos
y es evidente que este punto de aquí es
un valor atípico el residuo entre este
punto y la recta es muy grande será un
residuo negativo así que este punto está
disminuyendo la r y está disminuyendo la
pendiente de esta recta de regresión si
quitamos este valor atípico es probable
que tengamos una recta que s
así y parece que tendremos un mejor
ajuste la razón por la que la recta no
está haciendo esto es porque trata de
acercarse a este punto de aquí si
quitamos este valor atípico nuestra erre
se va a incrementar
y también se incrementará la pendiente
de nuestra recta
tendremos un mejor ajuste a estos datos
positivamente correlacionados y ya no
tendremos este punto que está jalando
hacia abajo la recta veamos cuáles
opciones aplican incrementará el
coeficiente de determinación r al
cuadrado bueno si r se incrementa r al
cuadrado también se incrementará esta
opción aplica el coeficiente de
correlación r se acercará a 0 no de
hecho se acercará más a 1 porque
tendremos un mejor ajuste aquí esta
opción la descartamos incrementará la
pendiente de la recta de regresión de
mínimos cuadrados efectivamente este
valor atípico está jalando hacia abajo
la recta y si lo quitamos permitiremos
que la pendiente aumente esta opción
también aplica hagamos otro ejemplo la
siguiente gráfica de dispersión muestra
un conjunto de datos y variados con su
recta de regresión de mínimos cuadrados
considera eliminar el valor atípico 10
menos 18 este de aquí y calcula una
nueva recta de regresión de mínimos
cuadrados
qué efecto tendrá esto así como está la
recta de regresión tenemos una pendiente
negativa por lo que tenemos una r
negativa así que sabemos que r es mayor
que menos 1 y menor que cero sin tener
que quitar el valor atípico sabemos que
erre no puede ser igual a menos 1 porque
de ser así la recta con la pendiente
negativa pasaría por todos los puntos
pero si quitamos este punto qué va a
pasar esta regresión por mínimos
cuadrados está siendo jalada hacia abajo
por este valor atípico por lo que si lo
quitamos esta recta se moverá hacia
arriba del lado izquierdo por lo que
tendremos una recta que luce así estoy
dibujando esto a mano e incluso así se
nota que tenemos un mejor ajuste con los
puntos reales la nueva línea que dibuje
después de quitar el valor atípico tiene
una pendiente aún más negativa por lo
que al eliminar el valor atípico
disminuimos r y se acerca más a menos 1
haciendo que esté más cerca de ser una
correlación negativa perfecta y además
disminuirá la pendiente qué opciones
coinciden con esto
disminuirá el coeficiente de
determinación r al cuadrado seamos
cuidadosos r ya era negativa si la
disminuimos la haremos más negativa si
elevamos al cuadrado algo que es
negativo no se volverá más pequeño
digamos que antes de quitar el valor
atípico herrera aquí voy a inventar un
valor menos punto 4 y después de quitar
el valor atípico r es más negativa y es
igual a menos punto 5 si elevamos esto
al cuadrado
tendremos punto 16 positivo y punto 25
positivo erre ya es negativa y si la
hacemos más negativa entonces no va a
disminuir el real cuadrado de hecho lo
va a incrementar así que esta opción no
aplica incrementará la pendiente de la
recta de regresión de mínimos cuadrados
no de hecho va a disminuir va a hacer
una correlación negativa más fuerte
esta opción tampoco aplica incrementará
la intercepción de iu de la recta de
regresión de mínimos cuadrados si al
deshacernos del valor atípico podemos
pensar que este lado izquierdo
a subir otra forma de pensar en esto es
que la pendiente de esta recta va a
disminuir se volverá más negativa
sabemos que la recta de regresión por
mínimos cuadrados siempre pasa por la
media de ambas variables va a girar
alrededor de la media de ambas variables
lo que significa que la intercepción de
i va a aumentar esta opción se aplica y
con esto terminamos